the goal of this video is to help us
visualize what's going on with the
solution
at a microscopic really at a molecular
level
and also to get practice drawing these
types of visualizations because you
might be asked to do so depending on
the type of chemistry class you're in so
what i have here are three different
aqua solutions which means that the
solute is dissolved in water
the first one is sodium chloride then we
have magnesium chloride then we have
c12h22o11
which in other words is sucrose and each
of them are dissolved in water what i'm
going to do is i'm going to try to
do a drawing of what's happening at a
particular level
in the respective rectangles right below
them
so first of all let's think about what
happens with sodium chloride
so the first thing that you might
realize is that sodium chloride this is
an ionic compound
it's made up of a sodium
positively charged ion or cation
and a chloride negatively charged ion
and if i want to draw them and they're
going to be in a one to one ratio for
every sodium there's one chloride
and i could think about their relative
sizes and to help us do so
i'll get out the periodic table of
elements and we can see here
that they're both in the third period
and if we're just looking at the atom
a sodium atom versus a chlorine atom the
general trend is as you go
to the right and you have more electrons
in that outermost shell
the radius tends to actually get smaller
so a chlorine atom is actually smaller
than a sodium
atom but we're not talking about atoms
we're talking about ions
so positively charged sodium ion that
has
lost an electron so it actually has an
electron configuration of neon
while the chloride anion has an electron
configuration of argon
so it actually turns out that the
chloride anion
is going to be larger than the sodium
cation
and so what i will do is i will
represent the chloride anion
looking like this i'll put a negative
charge there
and for the positively charged sodium
cation i will make it a little bit
smaller
something like that and if i wanted to
visualize it for every
sodium positively charged ion
i would also have to draw a chloride
anion
so that's one of them and then you might
say okay well that's the solute but
where
is and sometimes they actually just ask
you just to draw the solute in which
case you would be done but
if you're wondering well how is that
interacting with the water and this will
even help us understand what's happening
why sodium chloride why ionic compounds
dissolve
well into water well then we have to
draw the water molecules
and if we still want to get the relative
sizing right we can go back to our
periodic table of elements
and we know that the sodium cation
has an electron configuration of neon
and oxygen is pretty close
to that and when we're talking about
water the oxygen
atom is hogging the electrons it's the
electrons are spending a little bit more
time around the oxygen than around the
hydrogens
so it's actually going to be similar in
size an oxygen in water
and a sodium cation and obviously these
aren't going to be
exact drawings but we can imagine
each water might look something like
that so it's an oxygen with two
hydrogens i'll just do it all in this
white color right over here and then the
question is what would their orientation
be and that's really important to get
right especially when you're dealing
with water which is a polar molecule
we know that the electrons spend more
time around the oxygen we've talked
about this in many videos
so the oxygen end has a partial negative
charge
while the hydrogen ends have a partial
positive charge
and so the orientation of a water
molecule is that the the partially
negative oxygen end will be attracted to
the
positive ions and then the positively
charged hydrogen ends will be attracted
to the
negative ions so you might have
something like that this oxygen
and then the two hydrogens you might
have an oxygen
and then you have the two hydrogens
because the hydrogens
that end of the water molecule has a
partially positive charge
they're going to be attracted to this
chloride anion
you might have once again the two
hydrogens
and then the oxygen and once again the
oxygen is going to be
attracted to the sodium the positively
charged sodium cations
and i could keep filling these in for
into in this entire space but i think
you get the idea
of what the water would kind of look
like and how it would be oriented
now for these next two let's just focus
on the solutes what would the solute
look like
in the solution well magnesium chloride
this once again
is an ionic compound and so it is going
to
disassociate into its constituent ions
for every one magnesium ion actually
going to have a
plus two charge you're going to have two
negatively charged
chloride anions and what's the relative
sizing
well to help us with that we go back to
the periodic table of elements
and if we're talking about a magnesium
two plus or positively charged
ion it's still going to have an electron
configuration of
neon and it's going to have more protons
than the sodium ion so it's going to
pull
even harder on them so it's going to be
even smaller than the sodium ion
so we could draw the magnesium ions like
this
maybe i'll do two of them so i'm going
to do it even smaller
than the sodium and i'll write 2 plus
because it has a positive 2 charge i
will write
2 plus again because it has a positive
charge and for every
one of those you're going to have two
chloride anions
so maybe one there maybe one there
maybe one there and then
maybe one there and then if you were
asked to draw
the solvent draw the water you would
orient it similarly
where the pot the partially positive the
hydrogen ends of the water
would be attracted to the negative
chloride anions
and the oxygen end of the water
molecules would be
attracted to these plus two charged
magnesium
ions now what about sucrose it isn't an
ionic compound so in this situation it's
not going to disassociate
so a sucrose molecule is relatively
larger
i'll draw it like that maybe we have
another one
just like that and the reason why it
dissolves in water well is
a sucrose molecule has parts of the
molecule that have polarity to it it has
a lot of oh groups
so there's parts of the molecule that
are partially positive and other parts
of the molecule that are partially
negative other parts that are partially
positive
and so that's able to be attracted to
the various ends depending on whether
it's partially positive
partially negative of the water molecule
and so i'll just write it like this
c12h22o11
c12h22o11 for the sake of time i haven't
drawn the water molecules here
and to actually make to draw them
intelligently you would have to know
what parts of this larger molecule have
a partially positive
or partial negative charge but as we'll
see
the fact that you can either
disassociate into
ions that clearly have charge or that
you have a larger molecule where parts
of it
have a partial charge or have some
charge associated with it
that's what allows it to dissolve well
into a polar solvent
like water